I learned Hanukkah lasts eight days and
eight nights right that's what I learned
yeah if if your Chanukah lasts longer
than that consult your doctor
[Laughter]
I'm the wrong spokesman from yeah yeah
seems like you don't understand it I
don't know I don't know what's going on
Jeff frost you under you understand the
hanukkah right he doesn't get excited
about anything no this is Jeff Ross
winning at 800 million dollars in the
lottery won the lottery and then finding
out there's some soup oh there's some
soup I'll get soup hey any fight fans
did you watch that fight this weekend
good god that was crazy over the weekend
Mitt Romney did you know this Mitt
Romney met Manny Pacquiao just before
patty L lost his boxing match to Juan
Manuel Marquez he met him just before
you yeah afterwards Romney told Pacquiao
you lost for the same reason I did young
Hispanics
[Applause]
[Music]
I don't think could see was in the crowd
on Saturday night Mitt Romney Snooki and
Steven Seagal were all spotted at the
boxing match yeah the whole crowd was
made up of people we won't remember in
three years two story that's a true
story that was more of a kind of true
more true than funny NASA I couldn't
believe the story NASA has hired prison
inmates to build satellite parts that's
a true story yeah it's all part of
NASA's new program to search for signs
of life in the universe and then make
them our [ __ ] over the weekend hundreds
of men took part in Boston's annual
Santa speedo run in other words no one
in Boston is going to be happy this year
with their Christmas package the hell
was that I just looked that way she went
okay
I know it wasn't that good
big news taylor swift's turns 23 this
week yeah Taylor said she's at that age
where she just wants to settle down then
break up and then write a hit song about
it
hold for editing
[Applause]
get this gang the other night on The X
Factor Britney Spears said a 13 year old
contestant reminds her of herself
yeah the 13 year old thank Britney for
her comment and immediately quit show
business
[Applause]
[Music]
gotta mention this a store in New York a
store New York has a service that allows
customers to scan their penis and then
print out a 3d replica that's true my
question is do they do enlargements
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
am i doing you're getting here I guess
seven seven-year-old me workout tonight
though getting a real barn back here if
I had an ass it would be on fire right
now have us no ass no right no ass at
all through the street drop thanks pal
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna sell you out
in front of people if you say it's true
it's true